here is Rachel Levine Rachel Levine is
our Deputy Health secretary whose real
name is Richard Levine dick Levine
here's I'm sorry Daphne I'm sorry it's
just it's writing itself today it really
isn't me
anyway here's dick Levine uh defending
child trans surgery in a speech last
week
across the United States including
Children's National Medical Center down
the streets including Children's
Hospital of Philadelphia including
Boston Children's Hospital Seattle
Children's Hospital
Medical Center in Ohio and many others
who provide extra 10 Decor if your child
has diabetes you would go to a pediatric
endocrinologist
treatments
I think we need to work together
I think we need to work together to stop
communicate by communities
I think we need to talk to school board
dick Levine is just a disgusting human
being why that person wants to
chemically castrate children
their brains are not developed enough
there's a reason you don't let
seven-year-olds Vote or seven-year-olds
drive a car but you want a
seven-year-old who might think that
they're an Autobot one day or a Jedi the
next day or Barbie the day after that
you want them to decide whether they can
literally chop their genitals off and
then what their and then with no with no
concept of how their life will be after
that what you have up there is a man
dressed as a woman with a penis telling
other people's children that they should
chop their nuts off now you might think
that's a little bit odd in and of itself
but then this video came out over the
weekend this is Dick Levine in 2019
opposing child trans surgeries because
he's happy that he has kids
but I have no regrets because if I
transitioned when I was young and I
wouldn't have my children
I can't imagine a life without my
children
and so every experience led me to here
and
um and so how could I regret that it's
so insane do you see that what dick
Levine wants to do is ironically take
away the choice from these children that
dick Levine himself is very thrilled
that dick Levine did Dick Levine who
lived as a man until five years ago and
had kids doesn't want kids to have that
opportunity it's in essence he's saying
this is the greatest thing ever I had
kids so I'm thrilled that I delayed it
but dick Levine with his penis is trying
to make sure that other people can't do
it
[Music]
thank you